do we want winter park or redwood park
let's use the new one
i it's not so much that the park's new
let's do redwood but it's like the
entire game has been remade yeah he's
got a pumpkin on his head now so that's
pretty cool well i think there's also a
way where you can play as bigfoot but i
think they're like i didn't set that one
up no no no i don't want that oh my god
is there rick and shane
no
rick jessica thomas and william who
gonna be whom
uh
i'll be william i'm going to be rick
then all right do people ask me is this
like bigfoot this is bigfoot it's a lot
like that's your question it's
very similar so much like bigfoot that
you could say it's exactly bigfoot i
seem to remember sucking a big one at
this game before yeah we did we were
terrible no no no
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah a week ago
oh
you can do it
go ahead
no that's fine you can go ahead
i did it i read the part i wanted to
read after you all right a week ago
go ahead tragedy okay go ahead mark
struck
in redwood the bodies
of four people were found a middle-aged
woman
and free college students mutilated
by some
[ __ ]
come on man
we're doing a thing this is our best bit
we've ever done that's the funniest
thing i've ever heard
[Laughter]
god damn it all right all right time to
get down to business
boys wow look at all the buttons i love
that wow i'm gonna remember all of these
buttons okay g's activate explosives how
can we forget g is activate explosive
that's very odd g for go boom
got him
and good job holy mouse sensitivity
batman oh my god all right i think i
remember that
oh yeah that's special i'm just setting
for that one all right tablet okay ow
wow
i walked through the fire fire burns
well it's hard to be upset about that
that seems like my fault
all right i got one trap i got one it's
hard to heal
you know
eel can i get one coffee one laptop no
but one pumpkin
nope
okay one med kit
there's one gun here i i don't like that
there's a there's a there's a long range
gun and a pistol in here uh-huh you guys
go ahead i don't need a gun to fight
bigfoot well i get extra uh weapon uh
melee damage and gun damage so i guess
i'm the fighter okay
i'm gonna take the long range
done
i'll leave the pistol for one of you
players i'll flare
okay i'll do i'll sit on my ass and do
nothing mark there's literally a pistol
right there whoa there's a pistol here
come on kiddo grab your gun all right
paul i got it damn it you're the kid
yeah oh
so we're here to find bigfoot and we
won't leave until we get his ass i took
the drone but how do i do it one through
four something like that
it's like not appearing did i not take
it i for inventory i have the drone
there's nothing i can do with it what it
doesn't show up on my item wheel well
we'll figure it out later i'm sure it's
fine it's fine shall we mosey oh yeah
what do we do here
well we hunt the bigfoot we hunt to
bigfoot yeah what else does this [ __ ]
do william you're obviously the most
experienced hunter so you'll be our
leader yeah you go first you know all
right thanks i think we gotta go
uh
this and wait shelter two
yeah
we don't want that we want the grant
grove village
okay i think anyway uh you would know
best our very uh experienced colleague
thank you for recognizing my skill and
ability
of course
everything sounds and feels right about
being out here
i like it
the best way to find bigfoot is to not
tell any of your family members that
you're gonna go out into the middle of
the woods and also buy no health
insurance and leave no will
it's the only way to get them
you can't leave yourself william sure
reason this oh hey look like a totem or
something i can take it i got it now
it's mine oh okay well i was gonna sort
of inspect it or whatever but that's
fine oh no it's fine i gotta you can use
this tone to revive your friend with
stonehenge
what stonehenge where is the eye and
that's what it says aren't we in redwood
forest like
yeah we're in forest england obviously
we're just a a hop skip and a jump from
the sphinx uh everybody knows the
classic setting of stonehenge the great
redwood forest uh-huh yeah i remember
robin hood trapsing through a red one
did you give me the drone and the drone
battery do you guys hearing the slam any
slammities i guess you did
yes i did did you put the drone battery
in the drone i don't even know how you
would do that i don't know either all
right let's i don't even know how you
had to do that
guys look at the windsock
it's windy
how windy you might ask
very oh campfire guitar i knew you'd say
it i knew it i knew you'd say
all right buddy look at my muscles give
me all the attention
i bring the guitar so i can [ __ ] your
wife
whoa
whoa uh bob there's plenty of animal for
you here in this one uh mark there's a
phone here for you it's red ah thank you
here i'll close the curtain so you can
make your call in privacy thank you
thank you i don't want anyone seeing you
make those phone calls appreciate it
[Music]
uh you're right i touched a megaphone
that apparently was just
waiting to make some noise
yeah good i'm just gonna
it could it could be bad
i'm just going to close these curtains
on these busted out windows real quick
i'm going to close all the curt i like
privacy
yeah tons of ammo go get it there we go
you guys don't like the camera i'm just
gonna
i'm just taking care of myself
yeah all right
oh come to papa all
[Music]
guys axe big bob i need to give you
something is it a big axe no no hey
you're wasting your flashlight battery
down here here here wait wait for it
and your waste your flashlight battery
axe big
wait can i throw this
oh yes
guys
doing trick shots and [ __ ] do it again
yep that someone stand by the can i get
a volunteer to stand in front of the
tree imagine there's an apple
yep
[Laughter]
he's unharmed
all right do me do me oh dude
that's not the right thing hang on i
know what the tools i'm getting there we
go yeah all right no don't crowd chop it
down like that i need to aim carefully
all right this one is going to go right
past your elbow
stand very
very still
[Laughter]
all right bob now i you i you okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
hey
no don't pull it out that's bad oh is
that bad
do i have health because i don't seem to
have lost any health anywhere what was
that
uh
what
what is happening are we under attack
what the hell
um
mr foot
mister sir
mister or mrs
big
that's a dead body all right creator
crowbar looks like there isn't much left
i went deep into the forest please don't
look for me wait i need time alone
thank you
love you all tell my family john coleman
i thought you were just talking i didn't
know you're reading a letter there's a
note on his there's a note in his
separate hand no he's not very
drawn together
you just want to try over something
are you sir
are you all right are you he's not he's
not listening to me he's not paying
attention hey john
oh god
oh geez
that's kind of messed up they're going
to try to click on them see if maybe
that'll cheer him up i already did hey
you guys want to see me
throw an axe between his neck and his
head and his body yeah
nailed it
[Music]
are you hearing something
nah
are you getting wood wooden woodlands
madness are you okay bigfoot i'm fine
i just could have sworn i heard things
rustling closer
i think you're finally just losing it
all right okay um did we explore the
whole village did we actually get
everything
what are you guys hearing that you
hearing that
where that seems like something it's
over here fellers all right let's find
out what it is mr foot
sir
watch out bob you're getting a little
far ahead don't don't keep all the foot
to yourself i actually you know what i
did just hear russell like in that area
oh i disturbed the crows the horde's
coming wrong game wrong game
okay
is that a gas station what's that down
there
uh
i could go oh yeah
bean burritos all right let's go
stop hate that things oh is this the way
out of the park because it's like the
the probably barred off exit welcome
to
jurassic park
you okay
you're right i'm just just testing it oh
that's what the thumping is someone else
was down here beating the third oh
oh oh hey you there's like some rocks
sliding yeah i saw that probably fine
more rocks there's a totem here there's
glowies no this is just fireflies
oh there's uh some more buildings up
there i think that might be the village
though
oh no excessive noise or loud music
that's why i can't fire guitar guys dead
whoa
noises
what was yours
did i do that
i don't know that was not how guns sound
i wonder what voice chat's like in this
game hello hello not kind of quiet how'd
you do that
hello hello
i mean it kind of sounds proximity
yeah it kind of does oh it is probably
it is proximity it's delayed it's great
is it delayed yeah a little
that's fine we're good here crystal blue
not like we'll ever get split up and
need to use it anyway we would always be
close enough
you're right
okay
we'd never leave your side hey where's
bob
i'm i there's your name's glow in the
dark i'm never gonna lie no it's trying
to be dramatic
oh
um
is that good
i'm gonna hide behind this tree i will
stand out in the open well it came from
this way
yeah well what do we do is go adam i
think so yeah we got the guns here
yeah basically invincible yeah
where's that shotgun i had in the
loading screen
i have it in my arms
i thought did anyone
did anyone take the pistol from the rv i
did yeah marked it okay good
i didn't know he already had a shotgun i
don't know without a weapon i've only
got a flare
oh here let me give you let me give you
let me give you here
here you can take uh you can take you
can take the shotgun
oh i took it very kind of you
i feel like there's a lot what
uh ammo for your big gun
oh thanks uh-huh
oh hey guys
he's got a sock why he's got a sign
throw your axe do your trick
and he's following us
he whacked me
oh guys
oh i'm not dead
oh
why would i say that
oh i'm not dead
big fan
if he wants to go toe toe-to-toe i'll go
toe-to-toe i'll tell him oh he's towing
me his toes
did i get him off
okay okay that went really well
he's almost dead look at that we did
one
of his health
i don't like that gray part of the bar
that seems to suggest he could heal what
we just did
that's true
hey he's back he's back
guys guys guys he got a stick he got a
shovel
guys come in the house he probably can't
go inside houses yeah no way i'm in i
mean
oh hey oh
close the car
i think it's going well huh
i closed the curtains ah guys i think i
killed him
you did definitely he's gone forever
uh
unrelated unrelated there might be
another bigfoot
it's like aftershocks from an earthquake
it's nothing it's nothing
a guy
i put a trap down right now
nice big foot set a trap and i walked
right into it
oh i smelled meat and i went right for
it
i gotta okay
here's the first thing i'm gonna
i'm gonna stay can you get me off the
ground no i can't good job there pal
that's a really good trap it worked
really well
i decided to test it make sure
oh [ __ ]
all right i guess we'll uh
oh oh boy i had a trap down do not walk
into this trap
where's the trap at don't you dare
oh here it is there's a big symbol
marking where it is
yeah there is wow crazy that's weird
come on
i'm going to look for bigfoot next to
the marble fort caves don't go there be
careful ruby bray
hey there's something in the middle of
the road looks like meat you should
check it out
all right well we've made it to one
location and i think our first fight
with bigfoot was very successful but i
have a funny feeling that we'll need to
get more ammo so we best move to uh i
got one shotgun shell left i found a
drone battery guys
oh you want a drone to go with it i'd
give you a drone uh i'll look for monica
in the tree house i need to find her
ruby look around the waterfall peter
is this you yeah
assault rifle just pick it up and we'll
get it later
he's not close he's not close how do you
know
because i'm looking and he's not close
i'm close baby ooh i can take a picture
of this
nice
why belongs
oh evidence okay
i took a picture of uh some claw marks
just in case we didn't have enough proof
oh i should take a picture of him next
time he comes
oh yeah dude get his pick snap a pic i
will i'm moseying away from you guys for
a moment there's a okay
oh i found more ammo there's a lot of
ammo in the drawers that we missed uh
yeah that makes sense
we probably uh
probably need that
yeah okay i would grab all the ammo
it turns out the house that we were a
bigfoot attack uh peter can't find you i
found ruby's diary read it didn't take
it tell you tonight
he fought a waterfall
waterfall i'm by water waterfall yeah
head for the water i'm at the waterfall
me too something there
nope not that i see you under the water
is it in the water no i checked that was
the first place it looked oh game's
literally unplayable there's nothing
behind that that's terrible yeah what
the hell
i'm playing
i'm fine we really suck every house i've
gone into there's just been ammo lying
out in the open
listen man i found a dead body oh okay
oh cool
ruby bray didn't you read her note by
ruby
yeah yeah that was her note uh she's not
looking good bigfoot over here she
wanted to meet up with peter
i hate her
yeah
yeah oh no
wow she really has got to be more
careful with her walking sticks
oh
a camp
general sherman oh my gosh look how big
this camp is and archery oh that's fun
five five six ammo what i'm carrying a
gas bottle
but it looks like a big old metal
kerosene tank oh there's some
there's a lot of bones in this one
oh i got a big foot here
yeah you can handle it no way i very
much do
come on go run or something oh hey look
there's a fake pair in here that's
terrifying turns out that uh that
megaphone really works at calling him
that's great man that's great anyway
when you get done playing around come
join us i can't help but notice that the
health bar of the bigfoot is going up
yeah i think you're right
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
that doesn't sound very good
you